في دراسه لعلماء جامعه تكساس استمع
الباحثون الى نصوص المشاركين وهو منصورون
الى جهاز يقيس مستويات تدفق ضغط الدم الى
مناطق بالمخ ويستخدموا تقنيه يمكنها عبر
الذكاء الاصطناعي ترجمه افكار الاشخاص من
خلال تحليل صور رنين المغناطيسي لتدفق
الدم الى مناطق مختلفه في المخ هذه
التقنيه استطاعت تحويل الصور التي انتاجها
جهاز لقياس تدفق الدم نحو المخ الى نصوص
مكتوبه حيث استمع المشاركون في الدراسه
الى تسجيلات جديده وتمت مراقبه التدفق
الدم الى المخ وتحويل تلك الصور الى نصوص
مكتوبه وبالفعل كان المعنى هو نفسه مع
صياغه مختلفه للمقطع الصوتي الاصلي كما
طلب من المشاركين في الدراسه تخيل قصه في
عقولهم خلال اتصالهم بجهاز قياس مستوى
تدفق الدم الى المخ قبل ان يحقد القصه
بصوتهم كمرجع يمكن العوده اليه وبالفعل
ايضا تمكن الباحثون من تحويل تلك الصور
الى النصوص مشابهه للقصص التي تخيلها
المشاركون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات